We're still finding out details about this
just unconscionable tragedy that took place
in Beirut, Lebanon, a couple of days ago.
But we do now know enough that we can at least
say a few things.
On Tuesday, there was an absolutely gigantic
explosion in Beirut, Lebanon, at warehouses
that stored highly explosive materials.
And the video of this explosion looks the
way that nuclear weapons are often portrayed
in Hollywood films.
And it was, in fact, one of the largest explosions
essentially in the history of humanity.
Shock waves smashed homes and ripped off building
facades.
And so far, the death toll is at 157.
Now, just yesterday, it was at 113.
So it's climbing rapidly.
There's another 80 people currently unaccounted
for.
Ominously, and more than 5000 people have
been injured, but that those those numbers
are probably a fraction of what ultimately
is going to be uncovered.
Tragically, the shockwave spread so far that
300000 people were left without homes because
even miles away, the impacts of this explosion
were felt now very early in the process of
trying to figure out what happened on Tuesday.
Donald Trump wildly talked about this as an
attack.
He said it looked like a bomb.
And to be very clear, the reason I didn't
report about this yesterday is I knew Trump
had made those assertions with no evidence.
And I didn't want to fall into a similar type
of speculation.
And in fact, now, two days after the event,
it appears that what Donald Trump floated
was completely wrong.
Now, I'll talk a little bit more later about
him doubling down on that.
But to focus on what we do know, this appears
to have been close to 3000 tons of ammonium
nitrate, which can be used in fertilizers
and in bombs, which was stored for years at
the port in Beirut, Lebanon, after being seized.
Now, it was stored incorrectly, it appears,
without the proper safety measures.
And so far, it looks like inaction and negligence
are to blame for the explosion.
The words terrorism, attack, bomb are not
being used.
And from what we know so far, it was very
irresponsible for Donald Trump to use those
words.
There are reports that what triggered the
explosion was maybe related to construction
or repair work being done at a warehouse.
It's still early and even that has not yet
been confirmed.
And it is believed that these explosive materials
had actually been sitting there for somewhere
in the range of six to seven years.
So right at the blast site, it's complete
devastation and death in a sort of one mile
radius area.
There are partial and full building collapses
and many, many injuries in a two plus mile
radius from the blast.
You start to go in the direction of windows
blown out damage to buildings.
More on the injury side again.
And there are damaged buildings all the way
out to six miles from the blast, if you can
imagine.
So this is now a full blown disaster.
So it's a disaster zone.
It's a catastrophe.
Humanitarian groups are trying to get into
the area to provide help.
Other nonprofits and of course, everything
is in the context of coronavirus.
And that is significantly compounding the
difficulty.
When you have a raging pandemic, any kind
of humanitarian mission becomes more more
difficult.
And again, the blast is considered to be about
20 percent of the size of Hiroshima.
I mean, just think about the magnitude of
that.
Now, again, there is almost no important global
news story in 2020 in which our president
does not become a reckless participant.
And case in point, calling this an attack
early floating the idea of a bomb was completely
irresponsible.
At first it seemed maybe he was leaking information
from a classified briefing he had received.
Maybe he knew something that had not yet been
made public.
He didn't.
He was just wildly speculating, again, showing
that there's a level of irresponsibility that
he just can't get away from as president of
the United States.
And I'm going to talk more later about Trump
doubling down on it.
But instantly you have right wingers posting
everywhere on the Internet.
It is an attack because of what Donald Trump
said.
The reality is that we probably still don't
know the whole story, but that type of speculation
from a president is childishly irresponsible.
And in fact, there is a long list of ammonium
nitrate explosions, including here in the
United States, that you might even remember
in 2013, there was an ammonium nitrate explosion
in west Texas, which also led to speculation
about terrorism and attacks and bombs.
That's not what it was.
15 people did die.
So there can always be foul play.
This is not an out of the world unbelievable
situation as it's been reported and Trump's
ignorance and irrational speculation, as always,
causing more problems once again.